all right hello everybody I'm
Grandmaster Robert hungaski and today
I'm going to be doing
the class prepare like a pro
so for this class what I thought I'd do
is uh share a recent game
uh where I got a chance to play some of
the preparation that I had in mind right
so a lot of the times it happens you
know you you think you know what your
opponent is going to play you prep this
whole line and then something completely
unexpected happens but a few times we
actually get exactly what we were hoping
for and this was the case for me not to
say that you know all the problems are
solved but it's kind of interesting to
see how the expectation of getting a
position actually measures up to getting
it and this game was played at the
Continental Championship couple weeks
ago in the Dominican Republic
my opponent was a legendary Grandmaster
from Colombia Alonso Zapata
it's a very famous game where he beat
Anan in 15 moves and during the 1980s
and he was one of the strongest players
in Latin America so he's always been an
E4 player and he is a sicilian player
himself so
uh Cecilia and I had been dabbling in
recently was the Khan Sicilian and the
Zapata is probably the guy that knows
the most about that Sicilian in the
world so I wasn't going to try that
but there was another uh
Sicilian in the back of my mind that I
had been wanting to try for a while
because I had seen
a very nice game that Anish giri one
with black
and I also noticed maksudu playing this
variation a lot and that is the
Kalashnikov Sicilian
um
I think the the Sicilian is a very
popular
opening because it's so dynamic
it's not easy for white to
to find dry positions with which to kind
of kill the game most anti-sicilians are
not great
and within the Sicilian you can choose
from so many different options I mean in
this game we'll be talking about the
Kalashnikov
but you know you have
the other lesser-known
Sicilians like the lowenthal the oak
Kelly variation then you have the Dragon
family you have the naidorf the shavenic
instructors the Conwell it's
it's quite rich
but the interesting thing about the
Sicilian is that they all share the same
DNA
they all want to
arrive at the same position right by
trading the C Pawn for the d-pawn
black has secured himself upon majority
in the center and that's exactly where
our play is going to be sometimes we
associate the Sicilian with these crazy
dragon games or Bobby Fischer or
kasparov's nidorps or topolov's Knight
or shavenegan structures and
we forget that there's actually a very
simple idea going on here and it's going
on in the center
so the lowenthal variation has always
been one of my favorite openings I'm not
going to spend too much time talking
about it here I would really like to
dedicate an entire lecture to it if I
could but the idea of the lowenthal
is actually the most straightforward way
that we can carry out this plan because
if white plays a passive move
like Knight B3 then after Knight F6
Knight C3 Bishop B4 Bishop D3
our Dream setup comes true and black is
already better here
uh the same
or I guess analogous approach
is the old Cali variation this is
probably even sharper because
black doesn't even want to give white
the option of going Knight B5 right so
now if Knight B3 Bishop B4 Bishop D3 we
get a very similar almost identical
uh dream setup
so this is how the Sicilian was born
these are the oldest Sicilians the
lowenthal the O'Kelly and
everything has built from there I mean
today the most popular Sicilian of all
is you could call it a lowenthal or an
old Kelly variation
improved because
black is taking all these
precautions so that when the move E5 is
played there is no check on B5 there is
no Knight B5
and hopefully the D5 Pawn break can be
prepared
um
and carried out so that's really where
everything sort of meets the common
denominator
now in this game I played Knight C6 and
after takes E5 Knight B5 I decided to
play the Kalashnikov
variation because I noticed my opponent
didn't have that many games in it and
the games that he did have all featured
the move C4 which is the move that
almost everybody plays against the
Kalashnikov and it's a perfectly good
move of course I mean it makes so much
sense look at
how white is on point here white
recognizes the importance of the D5
square and engages Us in this tug of war
and with the move C4 white is basically
saying just just forget about D5 it's
never going to happen
and uh
the alternative Knight one to C3 is also
quite interesting I'm not really going
to get into it too much here partly
because I don't think I know it as well
as C4 and really for me the game started
after the move C4 I was 99 sure this is
what my opponent would play and he did
so after C4
the first
obstacle in the game uh needs to be
overcome like what are we going to do
about this clamp well
the maroxy bind is not just
a structure that's
um relevant in the Kalashnikov it's one
of the most important Pawn structures in
all of chess strategy
and it's even present in Queen Pawn
openings although there it's referred to
as samish structures but they're very
similar
In the Sicilian
usually once White sets up this clamp
black is going to have to try to chip
away at it from the sides right we need
to deflect the E and or the C pawns so
that white will loosen his grip over
this D5 Square we can finally get back
to what matters so after Bishop E6
Knight C3 A6 Knight A3 this is a more or
less the standard
Kalashnikov position I mean this move
Bishop E6 is not the only way of playing
I remember that uh for
a while after
Asics Knight A3 black was trying to move
F5 right away so this move makes a lot
of sense because
black is chipping away at
White's uh maroxy Vine right so now we
can play Maybe Knight F6 Bishop E7
cancels and then aim for B5
very interesting I haven't looked at it
in a while but I suspect there must be
some pretty big problem with it
and the other idea that I've seen is
Bishop E7 trying to trade off these
Bishops so usually trading off these
dark Square Bishops and maroxy buying
structures not a bad idea
but I had something else in mind with
Bishop E6 that was that after Knight C3
A6 Knight A3
I wanted to play
this idea
and this is
the idea that I was mentioning Geary had
assayed with great success make sure
they actually played it a whole bunch of
times against very strong players with
great results
now
foreign
let's see if that if that Geary game has
made it to
the leeches database
it should have let's see
um Anon make sure that's a good one too
I'll insert that one
but anyway the point of G6 might seem
like oh I'm just trying to put a bishop
on G7 and a knight on D4 and while that
is true like there are many situations
where I would definitely do that
I'm also preparing the idea of F5
in order to meet e takes F5 with G takes
F5 so I don't just want to trade off
your Pawn on e4 I want to bring my G
Pawn into the discussion as well
and
what's interesting about this
preparation that I'm going to be sharing
with you is that
it's not really about memorization
um understanding when to play F5
is going to depend more on your
understanding of the position than your
ability to memorize moves although you
could just memorize your way through it
it's not going to be the easiest and
most productive way so my opponent plays
Knight C2 makes a lot of sense covering
the D4 square and now after Bishop G7
this was a key moment in the game and
actually
something very curious happened while I
was playing this game was that I started
seeing moves that I hadn't that hadn't
even occurred to me in my preparation
I assumed white white was just going to
play Bishop E3 Bishop E2 and Castle
kingside maybe Queen D2 Rook fd1 F3 Rook
ac1 those were sort of the the moves I
had in mind
but it turns out that there's a big
difference in
which move we start with and when I
started to understand that I actually
realized that probably White's best move
here is Knight D5 because this is going
to be the central piece of the puzzle
and the reason Knight D5 is uh annoying
is well if I take on D5 after C takes
94 Knight takes Pawn takes Bishop D3
this could actually be a playable
position black could try to go Knight D7
castles rookie a knight C5 Rook C8
[Music]
um
but these positions do tend to be
slightly better for white for example I
don't know castle castle let's see
um
yeah maybe if instead of castles I go
Knight D7 first this could be better
yeah but F4 Knight C5
maybe B4 takes takes and these kinds of
positions that D4 Pawn is going to
suffer a little bit
so okay playable
absolutely
um
so you know once I saw okay Knight D5 is
not such a big deal also 95 doesn't
really threaten anything I could just go
Rook C8 first and I don't think that's
going to change anything but what did
seem kind of interesting to me was that
I couldn't play Knight F6 or Knight G7
too comfortably because of Bishop G5 and
this was a problem so Knight D5
we can take on D5 or playwork C8 but we
have to be very careful with with Knight
F6 so then I said okay that's taken care
of
what about castle in quickly
uh
this is actually
the the moment where I realized okay you
know
F5 is kind of delicate because
you would think that after Bishop E2 F5
would be very
interesting because after takes takes
the queen can't come to H5 right maybe
the bishop will give a check but
actually after king f8 the king is quite
safe on f8 and the bishop on H5 is
nothing to write home about my next move
is going to be Knight F6 and
um maybe Queen C7 97 Rook C8 B5 this
Knight can come to G6 King F7
these pawns are mobile so
this is exactly the kind of position I
was aiming for
but this turns out to be
quite dubious for black because there is
one fundamental idea and this is what's
going to determine the successor failure
of F5 and that is the move B3
and now this Bishop's coming to A3 and
white is going to really sink his teeth
into the D6 Pawn for example after
Knight F6 uh
right Bishop A3
Knight takes Queen takes
and I don't know if something like Queen
C7 for example
Castle Queen side and this is just such
an annoying pressure right maybe just F4
and the bishop on A3 is is just killing
our position
so
rule of thumb is
F5 not going to work if the bishop can
go to A3 so we really want to wait
for the bishop to come to E3 before we
even pull the trigger on this F5 move
and that was pretty much the extent of
my preparation
so when my opponent played Bishop E3
here I was like okay time to go F5 and
this was also quite impulsive of me
because it's not enough
that the bishop can't come to A3
avoiding a queen coming to H5 is pretty
important so really I hadn't appreciated
how important of a waiting move Rook C8
is because after Rook C8
you're kind of
keeping the position flexible you don't
know if the knight's coming this way or
this way to try to support Knight D4
Knight ec6 you don't know when F5 is
coming if at all maybe B5 is going to be
an idea
and you can't just uh waist Tempe like
crazy is white so you know if you go
Bishop E2 now I get the best possible
version one when where there's no Bishop
A3 and one where there's no Queen H5 so
now for example after something like
Castle kingside well your C4 Pawn is
hanging right so you would have to take
some precautions and
here this Knight is looking a little
shaky maybe I can go Knight F6 Knight E7
and B5 I don't know Knight F6
castles
and maybe just here
and try to go B5 if you go A4 maybe I
just go D5 and we finally
made it right we carried out the D5 Pawn
break it it took a while
took hard work
that we did it and now let's say tags
takes yeah this has to be a dream come
true for black
okay
so that is really the position that
we're aiming at and it's very possible
that you can get it because white has
made nothing but natural moves so far
um
so it turns out after Rook C8
it's probably best to go something like
Queen D2 and after F5
takes takes
and castles right and just go for the
pressure on D6 even though we can't get
the bishop involved at least the queen
will right and the point is that after
F4 takes takes takes if you take on E3
I'll take on E6 and if you go King E7
Now The Bishop's going to get rerouted
once again
to its ideal diagonal which ironically
is A3 f8 and that's the one
non-obvious detail that I think every
opening has like when you study an
opening you really need to find that
nugget of uh an idea that's
that kind of changes the evaluation
right that once your opponent sees it
he's like oh this is not as easy as I
thought
so
anyway I looked at this position
the engine was recommending Knight F6
just sacrificing this Pawn which is
actually a pretty interesting idea
because when I look at this I feel like
oh I'm just down a pawn but it turns out
black has
considerable compensation I mean Knight
A5 B5 is a thing E4 F4 is a thing Knight
G4 uh Bishop f8 maybe just Rook V8 so
tremendous uh peace activity
so going back
I
neglected to include Rook C8 and played
F5 right away and almost immediately my
my opponent took played check and
castled queenside
and this was actually pretty uh
I think a good decision by my opponent
because he's really optimizing the
pressure on the D file and this queen
I underestimated how annoying this queen
really was going to be on H5 because I
figured well I'm just gonna develop my
knight with tempo
but there are a couple of problems in
this position that are more serious than
they appear the first is the D6 Pawn
white is actually threatening Bishop C5
and even if black doesn't win the pawn
on D6 just rerouting the bishop to A3 is
a huge accomplishment because this
bishop on E3 is misplaced in fact the
Knight would like to come to E3 and D5
or start putting pressure on F5
and if I go well I did go Knight F6
right White's gonna go Queen H4
and now
there are two problems one is again
Bishop coming to C5 but the other has to
do with our King safety because it might
not look like it
but this is a fianchetto right it's it's
been a it's been a bumpy ride for this
bianchetto a lot has happened but all of
the same principles apply and in my my
lecture the other day when we were
discussing the benoni structures
I was mentioning how in order to
demolish a fiancado
uh there are basically three things that
need to happen one
you need to chase away the main defender
of the fiance of the king side which is
the Knight on F6
number two use the hook on G6 to open up
the H file that also seems fairly
difficult and unlikely in this position
since there is no Pawn on G6
and last but not least trade-off the
fiance Bishop
so White's going to have a really hard
time doing the first of these two things
but the other one's going to be really
easy right the whole point of this
uh
incursion of the queen is to trade off
the dark Square Bishops right so here I
played Queen C7 making sure that Bishop
C5 didn't happen and I got hit with
Bishop H6
so
Queen takes F6 is a huge threat I can't
if I take on H6 well that's check right
so after Queen takes Queen G7 the Queens
get traded off and then I lose my Pawn
on D6 that's bad
so I have to stop Queen F6
therefore I played King F7 and now after
takes
and 93.
so this this trade was an important
accomplishment for white and my position
is really on the razor's edge here
now
that's within acceptable parameters if
we play the Kalashnikov in such an
aggressive way
but something has gone wrong and really
the the lesson I took away from this
game was that allowing this queen to
give a check on H5 means that White's
going to be able to trade off my dark
Square bishop and I think that's what
put me at a disadvantage here and now I
have to treat the position
with great care already I can't do what
I would like to do which is to play B5
because white is threatening a very
nasty
tactic with Queen takes F6 followed by
Knight D5 right takes takes and white
simply takes the queen and remains up a
piece
so
I played the move 97 very important move
covers D5 so
make sure that Queen takes F6 is not
happening clears the C file
and prepares at some point the move
Knight G6 although I need to be very
careful because if I were to play Knight
G6 on the next move I would fall for
Queen takes F6 again
so
I was actually starting to feel pretty
good about my position I was thinking
well you know B5 is coming queen C5
maybe
um maybe maybe King F7 Rook G8 H5 and
then
Knight G6 like if I could really
consolidate that King sign I might just
win the game there
so after 97
my opponent played a very strong move
and after this move
I knew I was in trouble right played G4
and
this leaves me no choice but to take the
pawn if uh
if I leave the pawn on F5 voice is going
to take and go Rook G1 that seems
terrible maybe in Queen G5
if I go F4 I'm going to hit with get hit
with this in between move
right I mean there's a check here that's
coming there's takes I would have to go
Knight G8 and now maybe just Knight D5
takes takes takes takes
I mean what is this uh Queen Bishop D3
is coming I can't move in my knight
because of Queen H6 maybe Rook D1 King
B1 uh
yeah
black is pretty much busted here
so I have to take on G4
and now H3
it's clear that I should never ever
allow the G file to to get open right if
I go g takes H3 it doesn't necessarily
need to be a forced sequence you know
check check and checkmate but simply
Bishop takes H3 trade off the lights
were Bishops bring the Rook to the G
file play like a Banco Gambit
where instead of Pawns your king is
there and uh it's not too hard to see
that this is not going to end well for
black so have to go H5
and now
after Bishop D3 I have to be very
careful because now The Bishop's trying
to get involved
in the king side attack which is
actually not such a big deal
but what is a big deal is the other uh
so okay I can't really go Knight G6
again because of Queen takes F6 but also
Queen G5 might be an idea Knight F5
might be an idea Bishop F5 might be an
idea
but the real Point behind Bishop D3 is
to resume
this
um
dismantling of Black's King side
fianchetto I mean it looks like there's
nothing left
of that fianchetto the pawn on G6 is
gone the bishop on G7 is gone but
there's one thing left
and that is that night on F6 and it's
the only thing keeping this King alive
so the point of Bishop D3 is actually to
play Knight to E4
and after Knight to E4 trade off these
Knights and the queen will just do
tremendous damage for example if
I had played
something like
uh no not Rook f8
if I had played B5
which was one of the big moves that I
wanted to play then white was going to
go Knight before
and after Knight takes
Bishop takes
uh Now The Rook is getting hit Queen G5
is coming it's a very scary position
Maybe
I can barely hold on with D5
but it's scary
it says Bishop C2 and the attack
continues so
it's a scary position and I said well
let me just get my king out of
this situation
it anticipates any kind of check on G5
and most importantly
I'm engaging white in this tug of war we
call this the threat of the game right
there's there's finally something
that is of mutual interest to both white
and black enough so that we're going to
struggle over it right this is the
pretty much the essence of the threat of
the game finding
the main idea that should guide your
play so that you can arrive at the right
move
so the question is well why does this
stop 94 at all
well because now after Knight takes
Bishop takes D5 turns out to be much
stronger having played King F7 instead
of B5 is a huge Improvement right I get
out of the checks get out of the G file
protect my knight
we're doing great Bishop C2 now I just
go D4 and I'm just gonna keep pushing
your pieces back and your C4 Pawn is
going to have some issues
so white stays on the thread right you
need to think of the thread of the game
as that mechanical bull right that we're
we're holding on to and it's trying to
throw us off and we can't let
distractions take our our eye off the
ball so white plays very good move King
B1 and this renews the idea of 94. right
if we go B5
94 Knight takes Bishop takes now there's
no D5 because
there's no pin along the C file
here
I had originally gone into the position
because
I saw this move that I liked which I
ended up playing
which makes a lot of sense because after
Queen C6 it seems like
that's it the fight for E4 is over
um if you take on G4 takes
this kind of material imbalance
is not going to be a problem for black
as long as the Knight is on F6 because
otherwise
Rook H1 Rook H7 would be devastating
but this is why it was so important for
white to try to trade off this Knight on
F6 because then all of the ideas with
hg4 followed by Queen h8 are going to
work
quite nicely for example let's say if I
bring this Rook to G8
and white goes 94. and now after Knight
takes Bishop takes
let's say I go B5
Pawn takes Pawn takes now there's no
Knight on C3 and no night on F6 so after
takes takes takes let's say B takes C4
Rook D to H1 and this was one of the
variations I saw during the game and
which got me very worried because I was
like oh wait a minute Rook H7 is
devastating right if I go Queen A5
check King F6
check King G5 now at the very least I
would have to calculate well what
happens if Rook takes E7 do I have
Perpetual like would I be lucky enough
to get a draw here and I don't think so
I think after takes
check King C2 here
probably just
King C1 and you can even give up the
bishop because you're gonna pick up the
bishop on E6 so anyway
it looked like
once the knights come off
the levees
about to break so
I played Queen C6 and the moment I
played Queen C6 it was one of those
happens a lot you know that you have
this Moment of clarity when it's too
late once you've made your move
and when I thought the fight for E4 was
over I realized white has this
unbelievable move F3
if Queen takes F3 then simply Rook F1
and after Queen takes E3 Queen takes F6
followed by Queen takes E6 or queen
takes h8
and that's pretty much over
if I do nothing
White's just going to play 94 and if I
take with the pawn the point is that the
queen is now assisting the Knight to
come to E4 so after 94
Knight takes Bishop takes let's say
queen C5
this is just a nightmare because
the file is going to open like I was
really counting on that not happening I
mean I'll be lucky to to reroute my king
over to the queen side but I don't know
something like I remember during the
game
it was really funny
because it looked like I had almost a
resignable position
after Rook F1 but it turns out that
after Queen takes E3 Rook takes F3
instead of resigning I could also play
Knight F5 which turns out to be an
unbelievably strong move
because if Bishop takes F5 I'll take on
F3 or black is actually winning
if
Rook takes E3 I'll take on H4 still
winning
and well if Rook takes F5 just Bishop
takes and after Bishop takes black is up
in exchange I think I can even trade
Queens here with Queen F4 the game is
also over
so
um
that's kind of a cute move but of course
white doesn't have to go into any of
this white can just trade off the Knight
keep stripping the black king of its
Defenders and uh
I don't know for example if Knight takes
Pawn takes Bishop D7 now Rook F1 and
who's gonna stop
the white Rooks from just demolishing my
position right this is a winning attack
so F3 was pretty much winning in this
position and to my great relief
um being in severe time trouble my
opponent
played Knight C to D5 fairly quickly and
this is a huge blunder I mean this is a
this is one of those moments where you
feel like okay you know that
my opponent is the first one to to let
go of the threat of the game
because now with the Knight on F6 secure
I can play with uh
with pretty much the peace of mind that
my king is never going to get into
trouble
so
now white decides to go for this
variation with the Knight on F6 and it
turns out to be completely different
story
so uh
after Queen A4
Rook B8
Queen F4
Rook takes B7 a couple of really
interesting tactics uh
need to be attended to before we go on
this Pawn grabbing Expedition on F2
which of course is going to
open up
an Avenue for the Jeep Pawn to promote
but if black takes on F2
right away the Knight F5 and
that's not going to end well
and if I play E4 which I did right this
is going to attack the bishop and take
away the F5 Square after Bishop takes A6
I still can't take on F2 because of
another
nice tactic which is Knight takes G4
counting on Knight takes and Rook F1 and
white is actually winning now
so the key here is
to switch up the order of the moves
instead of going Queen takes F2 followed
by G3 I can actually start with G3
because F takes is going to be met with
Queen takes E3
and otherwise I'm just going to take on
F2 with the pawn and that's going to
serve
several purposes first of all I'm going
to keep the f file closed I'm big on
that secondly my Pawn is getting closer
and closer to promoting we now have two
connected pass Pawns
and they're supported by the queen and
soon both Knights so after Rook F1 takes
Rook B3
of course moving this Knight back would
just allow me to play E3 but now that my
knight is unpinned it's going to
cooperate as well so Knight D1 and here
the game just uh unfolds very nicely
right Bishop E2 94
threatening this triple Fork
and
after Rook B7 King F6 Rook H1
here black just wins by force right
check here and queen E4 and since I'm
threatening Queen B1 mate as well as
Queen takes H1 and there are no checks
well my opponent just resigned so anyway
this is uh one of the opening ideas that
I've been working on that I was lucky
enough to actually
get it in my game and even when I got it
I couldn't quite wrap my head around the
details in my preparation but maybe in
like two minutes of having it over the
board all of these things just start
jumping out at you like the importance
of the timing of F5 and that it's not
just about the bishop not coming to A3
but also the queen not coming to H5 so
we're going to do one more
uh opening let's see so that's the
Sicilian
uh what do we have here
oh
where's the French defense here we go
okay now we're going to talk a little
bit about the French defense
um
I play the French defense a lot with
black and uh
I actually
recently started enjoying playing
against it with white
and usually I play this move Knight C3
but also E5 the advanced variation is
probably the most aggressive
most practical way that you can play
against a French defense and Theory
isn't as excited about White's position
after E5 as it is about
let's say Knight C3 but in any in any
case this game featured Knight C3
and uh I knew my my opponent would
normally Play Bishop B4 in fact my
opponent said fide master from Uruguay
and I had played them once before
in a Blitz game and he had played Bishop
before against me and I think I played
E5
it was a crazy game
but this time around I decided I was
going to surprise him that I was going
to choose a move
that wouldn't allow him
to get the kind of position that a
winner were player is usually looking
for right and those kinds of positions
are pretty easy to to figure out you
know what they are because this is the
main tabia
of the winnower
and I would say if you had to
uh
Define the winner
in one sentence it would be get the king
over to the queen side right if black is
able to play Queen A5 Knight C6 Bishop
D7 Castle Queen side C4 black has
nothing to worry about the problem is
when this king gets stranded in the
center or even worse the king sign so
you know moves like Queen A5 Queen A4
are very popular these days also Knight
C6 Queen A5 Bishop D7 castles is
something I've played on occasion which
I think is also quite interesting
and then of course you have the 97 Queen
G4 Queen C7 Pawn sacrifice line which I
don't even know what's going on there
so I was like I don't know I don't think
I can prepare all of that in one night
so I played 92.
which has the simple idea
of
Never Letting black double our pawns
right and if we have to pay the price of
a Pawn on e4
to achieve that then so be it because
now after A3
Bishop takes Knight takes if you really
want to cling to this Pawn let's say if
you want to play something like F5
uh your dark squares are not getting any
better for example I'm not even going to
stress this Pawn right now I'm just
going to play Bishop F4 let's say Knight
F6
Queen D2
castles and castles
and
the secret to this variation
again it doesn't have anything to do
with memorizing
a bunch of long lines
but instead is understanding that it's
all about opposite color Bishops when
you play this Knight G2 line you are
very likely to end up in an opposite
color Bishop middle game
and that's the kind of position that
you're going to have to know how to
handle
for example I don't know if if Black
Goes B6 trying to get a bishop to B7
uh I could play Bishop C4 let's go Queen
E7 well then just D5 is is tremendous
but even if I couldn't go D5 these kinds
of positions
where
we Embrace and accept the pawn deficit
that we open up the E file and we start
drilling on this Pawn on E6 or maybe put
a rook the D Rook on E1 the other one on
G1
I don't know something like this black
is completely busted so hanging on to
the pawn is one of the worst things that
you can do as black especially if you
play F5 weakening your E6 Pawn if you go
Knight F6 it's really not as bad
but it will go Bishop G5 and if H6
Bishop here castles Knight takes E4
if you do something like Knight bd7
I'm gonna play moves like Bishop D3
Queen F3 Castle Queen side those tend to
be unpleasant positions for black as
well
so instead
black comes up with an active defense
and that is
to counter attack the pawn on D4 instead
of Defending E4 directly
because now if I go Knight takes E4
Queen takes D4 and what are we even
talking about uh black just has a
crushing position
so
the reason I played this variation I
mean I played this with black sometimes
and I thought the main move here was was
D5 and an interesting sideline was
Bishop B5
but when I saw the next move I was like
I I have to try this and it's a
beautiful move so move Bishop F4 and I
like it because
it's a recurring move
in the position which makes it
it gives it a little extra value in my
opinion when you see a move that keeps
popping up over and over again like this
bishop seems to always want to go to F4
and here even though black can capture
D4 in two different ways both captures
lose
because the point of Bishop F4 is that
I'm threatening Knight B5
it seems like a very you know simple
threat but it's actually very annoying
because if you play A6
then I'll go D5 and after Pawn takes I'm
going to reach your C7 Pawn this way
and you can't defend it
so black you might think well I'll just
go Queen takes D4 but then you run into
Knight B5
and if Queen takes D1 Rook takes D1 and
again there's no defense tonight takes
C7
if you go Knight takes D4
now I have Bishop E5 threatening D4 and
G7 and when you move your knight away
from D4 then again you get hit with
Knight B5 with a completely winning
position it's a great little opening
trap
my opponent played
the main move here Knight F6
which is a very important move because
it's not just about defending E4
but instead about
reacting in this thread of the game uh
which is the threat of Knight B5 by
countering with Knight D5 not just
defending C7 but also attacking F4
so black has managed to neutralize our
Knight B5 idea but here is where I think
the real essence of the position
starts to reveal itself because after
Bishop B5 we are setting up a trade
that's going to set up the main theme of
the middle game and as we'll see that's
going to be the opposite color Bishop so
after Bishop D7
now D5 takes takes right threatening C7
so takes takes threatening E4 so castles
now if I take rookie 8 and here we reach
another key moment in the game I
remember I actually played this in a
Blitz game in a couple Blitz Games and I
always used to play castle queenside
and this allows black to play Queen F6
which is a nice way of sort of
untangling on the D file
because if Queen takes D7
Queen takes F4 King B1
Rook d8 all of a sudden black has
everything covered
and black is up a pawn and black is got
pretty good pressure
and if I go Bishop E3 then another nice
active move Bishop G4 followed by Rook
d8
so this move is key right pushing the
queen further back into its own camp
and
after Queen C8 only then Castle
queenside so the Bishops actually really
annoying on G5 controls d8
uh it forced the queen to a very passive
square and now I don't really need to do
anything too special I could just take
this pawn and centralize my Rooks and
enjoy my Bishop pair
right and my better development and my
better King safety
so black really
uh uh doesn't want to let go of that E4
Pawn
so he plays Bishop F5
and allows me to take the pawn on C6
instead right and this is within
sort of the plan right this is part of
the plan getting this opposite color
Bishop position so
after rookie eight
uh Rook D4 Rook B8 Rook D1
I'm threatening Rook d8
so black plays H6 give his King a little
bit of breathing room and now Bishop E3
and
this position is very interesting
because I think that I
misevaluated at some point at some point
I lost the threat of the game
we'll see when exactly that was and how
I was able to sort of claw my way back
but what I didn't understand at the time
was how good the end games are for white
in fact White's main plan in this
position is to trade Queens
it might not seem obvious because you
think well when you have opposite color
Bishops on the board the important thing
is to seize the initiative to be the
first one and here White's Bishop looks
better than Black's Bishop but that's
not really true
it's not going to be easy to make
progress as white
without moving this bishop away from E3
and that's always going to allow black
E3 ideas himself
not to mention black has a worse Pawn
structure right this isn't necessarily A
Bad Thing the worst Pawn structure
usually means that
you have greater potential for peace
activity right so when you start hearing
okay opposite color Bishops greater
potential for peace activity this should
be a red flag going off saying I gotta
bail out of this before it gets out of
control
uh so I didn't realize how important
trading Queens here was and instead
after King H7 I played Rook A4 Bishop G6
and here I was still I was still pretty
much on the thread because I wasn't
in a hurry to play Rook takes A7
although there would have been nothing
wrong with this I think my opponent
wanted to go Queen G4
I think even here after G3
I know Rook d8
yeah this kind of scared me a little bit
during the game I feel like what's my
work doing here
apparently stockfish just laughs at you
plays B4 and puts the King on B2 and
says
game over fair enough because your
Bishop is dead
right so so this would have probably
been
the most clean-cut way of approaching it
but I decided to play Rook D7 and
sort of uh pick up the thread
that was begun with Bishop G5 right of
dominating the queen on C8 and not to
mention still threatening to take on C7
so now after Rook B7 here is where I
lost the threat of the game I I let go
and the mechanical bull just kicked me
right off
because this is not about pawns as long
as the Queens are on the board it's not
about pawns it's about peace activity
and it looks like black is just tied
down like all the black pieces seem
passive maybe rookie six is the only
idea
and that's why
very tough move here Rook D4
and after rookie six the point is that
we finally get
or trade and we get it under the best
possible
conditions because look at Black's
position it's just riddled with
weaknesses after takes takes
these pawns are going to get picked off
for sure I mean White's probably gonna
go B3 King D2 King C3 A4 Rook A8 and
it's going to be a very easy win
so
instead I played Rook takes A7 and here
what I missed was that after takes takes
E3 right another key move Bishop takes
E3 Rook E6 that when I take this Pawn I
figure well I have three extra pawns
sure he opened up the diagonal for his
Bishop that's very nice
but I didn't realize that after Queen A6
I've got all sorts of problems coming my
way I mean Rook C6 followed by Rook take
C2 is coming
uh that's bad
at Queen F1 followed by Queen takes G2
could be a perfectly good idea I mean
and if I try to go Rook D1 stopping
Queen F1 Rook C6 and I have to resign if
I go Rook D2 I also have to resign after
Rook C6 because then after check on F1
I'm going to drop C2 so all of a sudden
this game that I had completely under
control
uh
is off the rails
so I had to think for a long time here
and sort of readjust and get back
on the bull here and they played Queen
D5 which I think is is a good move
because
I need to take some emergency measures
here to defend C2 even if that means
retreating all of my pieces and all the
pain that would cause me having worked
so hard to activate them but okay it's
what needs to be done so after Queen A6
Queen D1
Queen C6 G4 Queen C4 King B1 Rook C6 and
Rook D2 and this was the whole point
right of of Queen D5 to be able to to
regroup defensively and withstand this
this wave of attack
I'm down uh what is it I'm down I'm up
two pawns and it feels like I'm
barely able to defend right that's how
powerful the opposite color Bishops are
now
I don't think
that black is able to add any more
pressure so I do think that White's
position should be winning
uh
and black played Bishop E4 yeah I don't
know the computer says that trading
Rooks could be interesting it takes
takes
I don't know I feel like trading works
just uh relieves the pressure
but otherwise what do you do well black
played Bishop E4 H4
and H5 right if if I can get to play
H5 then you know you might have some
King issues maybe bishop D4 F3 and your
Bishop could be trapped
so after H4 black sacks upon in order to
break up my pawns this is kind of an
interesting idea
and after Bishop D4 F6
so now I'm up three Pawns
and uh once again
the computer says just forget about it
this is not you know a position where
the Queens are helping so
we have to get the Queens off the board
and I think in the Kalashnikov and in
this variation of the French defense it
seems like in order to arrive at the
right move you need to understand
where you're trying to get to right and
the kalashniko we're trying to get to
this F5
with
certain
um
preconditions right like no Bishop on A3
no Queen on H5 in this in these middle
games of the winower
we're actually trying to get to an
opposite color Bishop end game with
Rooks right that's sort of the condition
and obviously being an end game without
Queens
so I played H6 this was already a little
bit of time trouble and uh after King
takes right if
if G6 I'm just going to go Bishop E3 and
Rook D7 if
if G takes H6 I'm just going to go H5
and you also have Sirius King safety
issues so you pretty much have to go
King takes and now after Bishop E3 the
only move is King G6 I was gonna play I
think H5 and now after King H7
probably just Bishop back to D4 and try
to figure something out
um kind of sloppy
uh apparently better than H5 is just
Bishop D4 and F3
and try to make something happen
on the G file that's actually pretty
interesting
um but fortunately for me my opponent
played King H7 and blundered a Checkmate
and in two moves
but in any case I think it was an
interesting game not just because the
opening went really well
but because I was able to understand
the the key relationship between the
opening and the middle game which is
trying to set up these uh pretty much
winning end game positions I mean if uh
even if the material is even with the
shattered Queen side
uh White definitely has the upper hand
so anyway these are two opening ideas
that I was uh looking forward to to
sharing with you and I hope you get a
chance to use them so thank you